CHRIS: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
My name's Chris [? Wallen. ?]
I'm an engineer here at Google
on the Maps team.
And I'm hosting today
Walter Voit and Srishti Goel
from Adaptive 3D
Technologies, and they're
going to give a
talk about what they
call their extreme 3D printing.
So without further ado,
I present Walter Voit.
WALTER VOIT: Thanks, Chris.
It's a pleasure to be
back here at Google.
As Chris mentioned,
I'm Walter Voit.
We founded Adaptive
3D about two years ago
as a spin-out from a
company that I founded back
in grad school called
Syzygy Memory Plastics.
In my spare time, I'm a
professor at UT Dallas
and run a research lab that
focuses in polymer chemistry,
in flexible electronics,
in radiation processing
and materials, and looking
at fundamental interfaces
of materials.
And in this quest to
make better, stretchier,
lighter, stronger
materials, we've
come up with some
really neat ways
to be able to build
them layer by layer
and make stronger,
tougher, 3D printed parts.
Let's get right into it.
So Adaptive started in 2014.
Up here is our management team.
I'm the president
for now until we
find sort of a
seasoned management
team, for which we're looking.
Srishti, who's here, just joined
the team a little while ago.
She got her Material
Science degree at Columbia,
and is leading a lot of
interactions with the companies
that we work with.
Dr. Lund is an organic
chemist by training
who specializes in a lot of
our new synthetic monomers.
Dan Patterson is
our first investor.
He's a seasoned private
equity guy back in Dallas.
He's bought and sold more
than 30 companies since 1993
and does a lot in the
middle market manufacturing
and business
logistics, and I think
has really come in and given
us a lot of experience.
He was a Harvard MBA
guy from the late '70s.
And finally, Brent Duncan.
He was the co-founder with
me of Syzygy Memory Plastics.
He and I were grad school
buddies from Georgia Tech.
He was in the MBA program
and I was in the PhD Program.
Brent also has a PhD in
Material Science and Engineering
from Duke University, and
spent some time with a nicotine
s startup company in
the Research Triangle.
And then has been working
with a lot of technology
transfer back in Dallas for the
better part of the last half
decade.
So what our mission and
what our job at Adaptive is,
is to really provide
services to large companies.
We work primarily with
large Fortune 500 companies.
Halliburton is our
first big, big customer.
We've also engage
a number of others.
And we're trying to build
parts that can't be made today
by conventional means.
So let me get into what
that market opportunity is.
In the past almost 25 years,
3D printing-- you guys
have probably heard it as a
buzz word, as a tech word--
and it means a lot
of different things
to a lot of different people.
You can 3D print metals,
ceramics, plastics,
so we're a niche.
We're just focused on
plastics, and within the area
of plastics, we've focused on
soft, rubber-like materials,
and viscoelastic
materials, materials
that have extreme toughness.
3D printing has had a 25%
compounding annual growth rate
over the last 25
years or so, and it's
projected to serve as a critical
part of the $16 trillion
manufacturing economy by 2030.
And you have to ask why that is.
Well, a lot of the big
companies in our space,
in the polymer space,
3D Systems and Stratasys
are two of the large players.
And I think a lot of
market hype sort of caught
up and even
surpassed the expec--
or surpassed the reality
of where 3D printing was.
If you look at a lot
of these stock prices,
in 2014 there were
some pretty big peaks,
and things haven't been
so rosy on the market
side for 3D printers.
And the reason is
because companies
have been unable to 3D print
high value industrial parts.
A lot of 3D printers and
3D printing companies,
we like to call the
Kickstarter babies,
have come out with
the shock and awe.
The hey, let's print something
really quickly, or let's print
some really complex widgets.
But a lot of the back
end market reporting
from Wohlers and
from other sources
has identified this giant
additive manufacturing market
as the real value add.
It's the idea that you
can print materials.
That if you print this first
layer, the second layer,
the third layer,
the fourth layer,
they need to be as strong
in this x-direction
or this y-direction as they
are in this z-direction.
And a lot of parts suffer from
this problem called anisotropy,
not the same in all directions.
And so with our background
in understanding polymers
and polymer physics,
we've focused
on printing isotropically
tough parts,
and have found really
neat ways to chemically
cross-link plastics
in this direction,
as well as in this direction
to make them strong and tough.
And in a little
bit I'll show some
of the materials properties,
some of the stress strain
curves.
I don't get too
nerdy and techie,
but that's sort of the
limiting problem that's
kept these kinds of
materials from being
a solution to
industrial problems.
Today, a lot of 3D printed
parts are used to print molds,
to print jigs, and then you'll
do conventional manufacturing
in those 3D printed molds.
But it's difficult to print
a rubber, to print a plastic,
and have that go
into an automobile,
have that go into
an oil well, have
that go into a tennis shoe,
have that go into a spaceship.
And so, what we're
looking at doing
is solving that problem
for a subset of materials.
So today less than 29%
of 3D printed parts
are used for functional
parts, and the market
is just a fraction of
what it could become.
So what have we done
over at Adaptive
to print these tough, high
quality rubbers and plastics?
Well, we've focused on
very scalable solutions.
So while we are synthetic,
organic chemists at root,
we've tried to limit the
design and manufacture of brand
new monomers.
But we use things that we can
source from large chemical
manufacturers that can be
scaled to meet a large market.
We've developed a very
nice patent portfolio.
A lot of the research has
been translated from research
at the University
of Texas at Dallas.
But we've been able
to build materials
with incredible strain
capacity, things
that can stretch five
times their original size
and then snap back into shape.
Or things today that have a
toughness of 16 megajoules
per meter cubed, and some
experimental materials that
are far greater than that.
And I'll get more into those
details in a little bit.
We also tune a lot of
the important properties
for 3D printed parts.
We've developed a new kind of
3D printer to make our polymers,
following a process called
SLA or stereo lithography.
But we've used Texas
Instruments DLP projectors.
You might have
seen the ads, it's
the little mirrors, little girls
with elephants running around.
Maybe you've got home
theater projectors.
I don't know if this is a DLP
projector, but it probably is.
But what we can do is
we can focus light.
These mirrors will
actuate at about 6,000 Hz,
and so we can turn light on
and off very controllably, very
selectively, and
we designed resins
that can be selectively
photopolymerized.
And we can very rapidly
print layer after layer,
and print a whole layer
at once at the resolution
of SLA technology.
So most of these
mirrors are spaced out
about 16 microns apart
in one of the machines
by the time you have your
throw angle down onto a part.
It's a little larger
than that, so in x and y
we've got feature sizes in
the 20 to 75 micron range.
And then in the
z-axis we can make
that as finely resolute as we'd
like, or as large as we'd like.
And that dictates a lot of
the print speed of our parts.
We've come up with
some really interesting
post-processing techniques.
A part of our process
involved only partially
curing this layer, so that
when the next layer comes on,
we get this full
chemical covalent cure.
And so we've got
some very interesting
post-processing steps that
help solidify these properties.
But at the end of the day,
instead of providing materials,
or providing
printers, we're really
working with large companies
to provide solutions
to underlying problems.
So for instance, with
Halliburton, they've
got some needs for very
specific geometries
in their downhole
completions team.
So they need plastic
parts that can essentially
help keep wells open
or help close up wells.
We need parts that have
a high strain capacity,
but have a high
toughness, and have
to be in pretty complex shapes.
And so those are the kinds of
things that we like to tackle.
So what we can do is
we can replace polymers
where you'd normally
use rubbers,
nylons, for a host
of different markets
that you see pictured here.
And by controlling the
monomer concentration, some
of the processing
characteristics,
and a host of the additives,
we've got a huge range.
As you can see up here
in the little profile,
we've got a lot
of different parts
that I'll play around with.
One of the things that
we spend a lot of time on
is we play with internal
structure in 3D printed parts.
So here you'll see
six little wafers
of the exact same material,
but the effective stiffness
of these materials
ranges dramatically.
So here's something
that's fairly stiff,
but it's also not very dense.
It's got near the
stiffness of a solid part,
but because of how this
lattice structure is created,
a lot of the stresses
are translated linearly
through the part, and so we've
got a very stiff material.
We've got other ones that
have the exact same density,
but by having different
internal geometries,
we have a huge range in
the effective stiffness
of these parts.
So by being able to selectively
control internal geometries
during this 3D printing,
we can do a lot of things
with the same material.
And then by changing
materials, we've
got a huge parameter
space to play with.
Here's some little Androids
we printed for you guys just
for today.
They also have little
microchips that
are embedded in
their heads, so you
can download a little TagWriter
app and scan over them
and they'll say something
fun to you guys,
if you want to come try
it out a little bit later.
Here's some dragons
that we've also printed.
And so you can get a sense
of some of the feature sizes
that we get.
These belong to a
class of materials
that we've done
a lot of research
in the lab, which are close to
materials called shape memory
polymers.
So these happen to be materials
called viscoelastomers,
or they're materials that
are in this transition state.
So you can see that when I
deform this dragon's wings,
they're sort of slowly
starting to recover.
Well what we can do and what
our lab back at UT Dallas
focuses on, is these materials
called shape memory polymers.
Here's a little
business card made out
of one of the shape
memory polymers.
But it's a material
this is stiff and glassy
at room temperature.
It has a modulus
of 2 gigapascals,
so it's just like Plexiglas.
Now if I heat this
up in my hand,
and get it to room
temperature-- or get it
from room temperature,
sorry-- to body
temperature, what
it's going to do,
is it's going to get orders
of magnitude less stiff.
So what I can do
is I can bend this
into some sort of
metastable shape,
and then as soon
as it cools off,
it's going to get very hard
again in this new shape.
So a lot of plastics do this.
If you've ever as a kid
played with liquid nitrogen,
you can stick a
banana in it and you
can hammer a nail into a wall.
Or you can dunk a racquetball
and hurl it against the wall
and it's going to shatter.
Or you could dip roses
in liquid nitrogen
and then they just
crumble apart.
Well we can design
materials that
undergo that same sort of
brittle to ductile transition,
but instead of over
hundreds of degrees
they can do it
over five degrees.
And so what we do is
we park these materials
right at the onset of
one of these transitions,
and then when that temperature
increases a little bit,
they get really, really soft.
So here are two very
similar materials,
but this is one where that glass
transition temperature, as it's
called, is just a little bit
closer to room temperature.
So as soon as I put
this in my hand,
it's just going to sort
of soften immediately.
And so it's going to go from
Plexiglas to silicone rubber.
And I can bend it,
I can manipulate it,
but then it holds this
new shape very, very well.
So a lot of this
engineering we've
done in designing these
shape memory polymers
is similar to the
problems that we
face in the 3D printing world.
What we're trying to do is
engineer cross-links, engineer
these multimonomer
solutions, engineer
the sterics of side chains.
So basically, how these
little groups hanging off
of our main chain polymers
interact with each other
to make things stronger,
to make them stiffer,
to make them tougher, to
make them less brittle.
And so a lot of that engineering
has gone into the materials
that we've developed
at Adaptive.
So what's the real market need?
This is a snapshot straight
from Stratasys's website.
Stratasys is one of the large
3D printing plastics companies
in the country.
And you can see
in the upper right
corner of that chart
they're missing
a whole swathe of materials.
So they've got an FDM
set of technologies,
that's on the left, that stands
for fused deposition modeling.
That's sort of if you'd
imagine taking a hot glue gun
and squirting it out
and building a pattern,
and then putting another
layer on, and putting
another layer on, you can
build materials quickly.
Their PolyJet process lays
down an unpolymerized resin
and follows behind with a
laser, or with a UV light,
and sort of spot cures it.
So our technology is
a lot more similar
to their PolyJet technology,
where we're curing something
directly out of a resin.
And the materials
properties we get
are up there close to
nylons, close to some
of these very high
performance materials
that 3D printing has
had a tough time making
in complex, arbitrary shapes.
So let's get into a few
more technical specifics.
Here's a host of non
3D printed materials
and what their mechanical
properties look like.
So if you look on the left,
that axis is the tensile stress.
That's basically how much force
it takes to deform a material.
And it's proportional to
the cross-sectional area
of that material.
PMMA is Plexiglas, that's
like this material.
So it's a fairly strong
but very brittle material.
If you look at something like
low density polyethylene,
high density polyethylene,
polypropylene,
they're materials with a lot
of give, with a high strain
capacity, but their strength
isn't quite as high.
And then you've got
materials like PA6.
That's a polyamide, or
a nylon base material.
And those combined have
a really high strength
with high strain capacity.
And for us, the
figure of merit--
and I think for a lot of 3D
printers-- the figure of merit
should be the toughness.
And the toughness is
the integrated area
underneath that
stress strain curve.
And that explains how much
energy a material can withstand
per cubic meter, or square
meter if it's an impact
test, or per linear meter.
And so what we'd like to do is
engineer materials that take up
as much space on this
graph is possible,
that are a combination of
being stiff and being strong,
but also having a
high strain capacity.
Now the modulus-- oh, yup?
AUDIENCE: Is that to
rupture, all those curves?
WALTER VOIT: These
are to rupture.
So these are the strain
to failure points.
And so what you see on
this far end of the curve--
let me get a laser
pointer out here
so people online can see me.
One moment.
Yeah, perfect.
So if you were to take the slope
of this line in the very, very
leftmost region of
this graph, that's
called the linear
elastic regime.
And that slope is
the Young's modulus.
And that sort of tells
you-- that's effectively
the stiffness of the material.
So if we want a material
that's soft and rubbery,
we need something with
a very soft or very low
slope right here.
But something that as you
strain it, it sort of strain
hardens and get
stiffer and stiffer.
And by doing that, we can
get a very tough material
that's very soft and
behaves like a rubber.
If we want an extremely
tough material
and we don't care
what its feel is,
we don't care that
it's soft or stiff,
but we just want it to
absorb a lot of impact.
You'd like a material that's
fairly stiff but not brittle,
and then as you get past
this yield stress point,
you have a huge strain
capacity until failure.
And I'll show you some of
our curves in just a minute.
But so what we have
is a couple ways now
to engineer the effective
stiffness of a material.
One way is by tailoring
the stress strain curve,
and another way is by tailoring
this internal geometry.
And this internal
geometry is not something
that you can do with
conventional manufacturing.
So for instance, let's
say we wanted to build
an insole for a running shoe.
A lot of that insole is
actually wasted material.
There are certain
points in that shoe
where stresses are
transferred from your foot
down to the ground.
If we could engineer
material for those parts
to effectively
translate the stresses
and have everything
else essentially
be a very low density foam,
we could reduce the materials
costs, we could reduce the
weight without any sacrifice
to the end strength
of the material.
There are no conventional ways
to manufacture parts like that.
That's why these market
projections think
that 3D printing has such a
place in manufacturing markets,
even though today it's more
expensive than injection
molding, than extrusion,
there are just
things that you simply can't do
with conventional thermoplastic
processing means.
So let's look at some
other parts today
and how 3D printed parts
stack up against them.
So what you see in
the top left here
are some of the
world's best materials.
They're some of the
world's best plastics.
These are different
combinations of polyestheramides
that have sort of a
stress of 10 to 18 MPa,
but have a strain capacity all
the way up to 1600 or 1800,
so this is something
you could stretch
to 16 times its original
size and then it's
going to sort of snap
back and not deform.
So these are very,
very tough materials.
Here are some materials,
some nylon based materials,
that when you combine them
with small amounts of carbon
nanotubes, or single-walled
nanotubes, or buckyballs,
or carbon fibers,
you see you get
this big increase
in their stress
without a large sacrifice
to their strain capacity.
And again, these are
non 3D printed parts,
but these are some of
the engineering methods
that are used to increase
the properties of parts.
So now looking
down here, what you
can see the difference
between injection
molded parts and then
a 3D printed part.
So here's an injection molded
part out of this material.
And this is a PA-12, so
a nylon based material.
And you can see how
little strain capacity you
have once this is 3D printed.
So when this is 3D printed,
those layers simply
don't stick together well,
so the neat material has
incredible strain capacity,
the printed material is tiny.
Same thing over here.
You've got this 250% strain
capacity for an injection
molded material.
You've got a 30% strain capacity
for the 3D printed material.
The story is the same.
Wohlers released a
market report in 2015
that looked at a lot of the
commercial 3D printed parts,
and most of the strain
capacities of those parts
were in the 10% to
30% range or lower.
But it was difficult to 3D print
parts that were a lot stronger.
Google recently was part
of a fund-raising round
for carbon 3D, which
apparently they
haven't released too
many stress strain
results of their materials
yet, but can print fairly
high strain capacity materials.
But perhaps at very limited
toughnesses and very limited
stresses.
So what are some of the
innovations that allow
us to print these materials?
Well the first one is
sort of a new printer
that we've developed
that right now we're
calling the Z cup model.
But what we can do is
we can package our resin
inside of something-- you guys
maybe have used Kurig K-cups.
You can stick a little piece,
a thing of coffee grounds
into a machine, you
can push a button,
and it makes some
coffee for you.
One of the big problems with
handling resins for consumers
is that you have to
handle those resins.
Often they can be noxious,
they can have odors.
We can package our resins
into these little sealed cups,
these guys plug in
to our printers.
We can manipulate the height of
something we've call a Z fluid,
which is a material
that's a little bit
more dense than
our monomer resin,
and then we can very rapidly
print things layer by layer
within these Z cups.
So what that printing system
looks like, would be you
can injection mold or mass
manufacture a Z cup that
looks like this, fill it with
a little bit of resin, seal it.
Depending on what
kind of resin, you
may have to remove all
the oxygen from the Z cup.
Some kinds of resins you
don't have to do that.
And then in the machine,
we can inject the Z fluid
and control how parts
are being printed.
So let's get here now to
some of the good stuff.
So here are some of the
stress strain responses
of competitor materials.
And we've been
able to get things
that have a higher stress and
have a much higher elongation.
These are some of the parts
that we're printing today,
we're doing some work.
I was at GE a couple months
ago and gave a big talk on some
of our 3D printing there.
We've done some work now with
the NNSA, the National Nuclear
Security Administration
on some 3D printing,
and with Halliburton,
and with a car parts
company called [INAUDIBLE].
They build some interesting
automotive components.
But we've got these
materials where
we can tune this
initial modulus,
so we can say how we want
these materials to behave
at room temperature.
But then we've got pretty
nice strain capacity,
so these stretch to 100%
up here at 15 or 20 MPa.
So this is a little
Chinese fingertrap
that we built out of
one of those materials.
As you can see, a lot of the
parts that we're showing here,
little toys and games,
a lot of our clients
don't like us to show
exactly the parts that we're
printing for them.
But what's also
really exciting is
some of the
experimental materials
that we have in development.
And so these are materials
that unfortunately
in a public forum like this,
I can't talk at length about.
But I can give you
a glimpse at some
their thermal
mechanical properties.
So this is a material with
close to a 400% strain
capacity, that has a
stress up to about 50 MPa.
So this has a toughness of about
100 megajoules per meter cubed.
So these parts that we're
printing right now daily
for a lot of our customers.
That's about a 10x improvement.
If you look at the 30%
percent strain capacity
that a lot of current
3D printed parts have.
This is between a 4
and a 10 x improvement
over rubber-like and
viscoelastic materials.
This would be another 10
x improvement over that.
And these are parts
again that have
very interesting properties,
but by tuning the polymer
chemistry, tuning
how they behave
as a function of temperature,
as a function of frequency,
we can do some neat things.
And so if you want
to follow up with us,
we'd love to talk to you guys
in more detail on the material
side, on the business side.
I'm sure she can handle
a lot of that follow up.
I've got a couple other little
side things I wanted to show,
some other fun projects
we're working on
back at the University with
some polymer chemists there.
But one of them is
being able to 3D print
self-healing materials.
So we've come up with
a really neat reaction.
This is a
furan-maleimide reaction.
It's been known for
a while, but we've
found ways to take
advantage of this reaction
and functionalize even
conventional materials like PLA
and like ABS with some of
these pendant side groups.
And so what you can
see here is a PLA blend
that we functionalized
with these furan
and these maleimide reactions.
And they undergo
a high temperature
reversible Diels-Alder reaction.
And so what we got
here is a material
that we broke apart
the first time.
And so that was
this point up here.
We basically heated these up
and shoved them back together.
We did another
stress strain curve,
then it actually broke at
a different point, which
we're really excited about.
So we were able
to heal something
basically stronger than this
point where it was before.
And so we think there's
some really interesting
opportunities for
taking very low cost,
conventional materials
and finding ways
to post-functionalize those
materials with pendent side
groups to give them some
interesting properties
in materials that
can be 3D printed.
But we think some
of the real success
lies in the ground up
engineering of systems
and of materials to solve these
really interesting anisotropy
issues that we see
in the market that
are limiting the broad adoption
of 3D printed plastics.
So with that, I didn't
prepare a whole lot of slides,
but wanted to leave plenty
of time for discussion,
and sort of
speculation about maybe
where this field is headed.
And wanted to get some of you
guys's take and interest on why
you're here.
So thanks for your time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WALTER VOIT: So the question
was whether the shape memory
polymers would fatigue as you're
bending them over many cycles.
And so it's a great question.
There's a curve in
material science called
an S-N curve, which
is a stress plotted
versus the number of cycles.
And so if you stretch materials
to their yield strength,
or the ultimate
tensile strength,
and you do that
repeatedly, then they
will fail after fewer
numbers of cycles.
So a lot of these curves
that you see here,
this is the failure
at one cycle.
So what most materials do
is you build in something
called an endurance limit,
which is a safety factor that's
some fraction of
this, and we can
guarantee that under
this stress profile,
a material will never fail.
And so typically
what you do is you
take some fraction of
your yield strength,
you make it less than that, this
is the linear elastic regime,
and then you can cycle material
hundreds of millions of times
without any adverse effects
to the network structure.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
even you warm it up,
it can become fatigued?
WALTER VOIT: So
when you warm it up,
it won't fatigue
unless you stretch
it pass this endurance limit.
And so we can define
an endurance limit
based on how stiff and how
stretchy each material is.
And you can heat it up and
cool it down indefinitely.
That will not have
an effect on things.
But when it's heated, as
long as you don't stretch it
beyond a certain distance, you
can keep doing that cyclically.
AUDIENCE: And about that
self-healing material,
is that a one shot
healing procedure,
or can it be repeated?
WALTER VOIT: This is one
that can be repeated.
So at high temperature, this
reversible Diels-Alder reaction
is sort of favorable.
So the monomers are just as
favorable as a joint polymer
as a function of temperature.
So you get to the
right temperature,
these reactions are
sort of an equilibrium.
So you can basically make
and break these bonds
really nicely.
So depending on
how many of these
we functionalize
onto our materials,
we can control how well
they stick back together.
Now, if you have
just a few of them,
then they're not
going to be as strong.
But the material is not
going to be as brittle.
And so there's a balance
then between ultimate tensile
strength, strain capacity, and
a lot of these pending groups.
And unfortunately in
a big talk this, I
haven't gotten into a lot
of the very hairy details
in polymer design.
But there are a
tremendous number
of features of the
monomers that we choose,
and how they interact,
how they polymerize,
what they're starting viscosity
is, what their side groups look
like, what the kinetics
of that reaction
looks like, that go
into the ultimate design
of these materials.
But today, I wanted to
just show the properties.
And say maybe some of
the market skeptics
out there, that we
material scientists may
in the near future
have a great solution
to help a lot of
these businesses,
who've really thought a lot
about 3D printing, but so far
haven't been able to
print the kinds of parts
that their customers need.
AUDIENCE: You talked
about the Z cup
for printing some of
these smaller parts.
How do you handle printing
some of the larger pieces
for like, oil companies?
WALTER VOIT: Well, the
reality is that this Z cup
model is highly scalable.
So we've joked
around a little bit,
but we could have a
helicopter lowering a giant Z
cup into a swimming
pool, and we could
print a canoe if we wanted to.
Now, I mean, that's a
little bit unrealistic,
but as a thought
experiment, there's
no technical limitation from
keeping that from happening.
It's just a balance of the
intensity of, in this case,
our light.
And we've played around
with both ultraviolet light
projectors and visible
light projectors.
And so depending on
the initiators we use,
we've got a lot of
control within our systems
over how they're initiated.
But we could do this
on very large scales.
We've built larger Z cups, that
are printing the kinds of parts
that our friends at
Halliburton like, for instance.
AUDIENCE: So one
of the things I've
noticed as a issue with
3D printing for production
is just the speed of printing
the materials, versus injection
molding or forging or
something like that.
And are you able
to address that?
WALTER VOIT: Not as well as
we would like, certainly.
So the question was
that in 3D printing,
speed is often an issue, and
that 3D printing can't compete
with injection molding, with
extrusion, with maybe blister
packaging, and other things like
that for making complex shapes.
And that is a true limitation
for a lot of 3D printing.
Carbon 3D, a company that
you guys have recently
invested into, has come up
with some really elegant ways
to very quickly print parts.
But a lot of the
customers that we've
talked to have lower volumes
that don't necessarily
need that kind of speed.
For them, the
driving issue really
is the underlying
materials properties,
and not the print speed.
So, I mean, these aren't taking
weeks and months to print,
we can print these in sort of
20 minutes to 4 or 5 hours.
So it's not that
they take forever,
but it's also not that we're
right now able to pull parts
out of a liquid resin.
But I think as we continue
working on making these faster,
I think that the driving
issue, for what we've
seen from a lot of the
market reports though,
is not that the volumes of
3D printed parts are too low,
but it's that the materials
properties aren't good enough.
And so I think we're
coming at this problem
maybe from a different
angle that Carbon 3D is,
is that we're really trying to
focus on printing tough rubber
materials, printing tough
viscoelastic materials.
And I think the
speed is something
that can be engineered
into the system,
whereas the underlying materials
properties maybe can't be.
SRISHTI GOEL: Walter,
can I add something
to this point really quick?
WALTER VOIT: Maybe
come to the microphone.
SRISHTI GOEL: So,
the other point
that in general, the
benefit of 3D printing
that a lot of people, I
think, miss when you first
start thinking
about the subject,
is yes, 3D printing
takes a lot of time.
But if you consider
the amount of time
it takes away from things like
having to redo your tooling
costs, to actually having
all of the other changes
you have to make.
If you have one 3D printer,
it can print anything from A
to Z, right?
You don't have to
change your tools.
You don't have to change
the assembly line,
you don't have to
do-- if you have
to change every single part
for some small specification,
you don't have to rechange your
entire assembly line to fix
this one small error.
You can just change
your SDL file,
and suddenly you're
there, right?
So when it comes to time,
that time efficiency
is spent more on actually
making the part than on making
all of the infrastructure
for making the part.
And that's where we see that
even though 3D printing might
be smaller and materials
might be more expensive,
at the end of day,
you're actually getting
a more cost-effective solution.
AUDIENCE: So a quick
question about,
I guess that you guys are making
the material as well as the 3D
printer.
How about like the
slicing in the software
that comes behind it?
Is that something
you guys created?
Are you using off
the shelf product?
Or, how do you do that?
WALTER VOIT: So we've done
a little bit of dabbling.
I'm on a computer
scientist by training.
I did my undergrad
in CS and a master's
in Artificial Intelligence.
That's how I knew
Chris back in the day.
He stayed on the dark
side, I went over
to the light side of materials.
No, so we've built a
few of our own systems
to print these materials.
So we've written some of
our own scripts and software
to run the printer
to do the slicing.
But to be honest, we would
love an infrastructure
like you guys's
behind that, instead
of relying on what we've
sort of done with chicken
wire and chewing gum.
I think there's a lot of
need for-- especially as we
get to some of these
complex internal geometries
that we've passed out, there
are a lot of very sophisticated
algorithms that can generate
fractal-like patterns, that
can generate complex internal
geometries, that can map,
let's say, a finite
element model
that you've generated in
Abacus, into a structure
that once you've 3D printed it,
you can localize the stresses
and strains appropriately.
I think that's a huge area
where software companies have
room to play.
I know that HP has recently made
some acquisitions in that area.
AUDIENCE: What's the
cost of the resin itself?
What's the difference between
just traditional nylon,
between [INAUDIBLE] similar
properties as injected?
WALTER VOIT: These are resins
that are not quite as commodity
as something like
polyethylene or polypropylene.
But they are not far if you look
at petrochemical distillation,
they're not far from crude oil
down the distillation pathway.
So if there were a
need to mass-produce
these kinds of
materials, it would
be very inexpensive to do so.
Because the volumes aren't
as high now as they could be,
they are a little bit
more specialty resins.
They're a little
bit more expensive
than traditional
injection molded parts.
But we look at what other
3D printing companies are
charging, following the razor
blade model of essentially
giving away printers and then
charging a lot for resins,
and at the lab prices that
we're making resins now,
we are more than competitive
at those price points.
AUDIENCE: Just a
couple quick things.
First you mentioned being
able to vary the Z height.
How far can you vary that?
WALTER VOIT: What's
really neat is
we can do that during a print.
So if we had some components
that structurally we
wanted to print some
layers very quickly
and we want a lot more
resolution in another layers,
we could do that.
It's a balance of
what kind of initiator
we have in the material,
what kind of inhibitor
what the height is,
what the intensity
of the light is,
and how these little micromeres
are turning on and off.
So a lot of
projection technology
has advanced algorithms that
make the edges, for instance,
look sharper and pixels.
So the mirrors are
turning on and off much
faster than the human
eye can see to give you
some interesting edge effects.
So there's some
interesting ways we
can play with that combination
of inhibitor, of initiator,
of layer thickness, and of
software to control that.
So one thing that limits
how thin we can do that,
is the viscosity of
our underlying resin.
And so different resins that
have different properties
have different viscosities.
In the lab, though,
we've been able to spin
individual layers that are
less than a micron thick.
In fact, we've been
able to spin down
some of these kinds
of materials--
now this is a solvent-based
approach where we have to let
some solvent then evaporate.
But we've been able to build
20 nanometer thick, very
uniform films, and do some
neat things with those.
Now, that's not really realistic
to print large area 3D printed
parts, but for some of the
photolithographic processing
we do, for instance, for
building microelectronics,
often we need a 20
nanometer thick dielectric
to do something.
And so we've got some abilities
to spin these materials down
to those thicknesses.
In terms of the thickest, it
depends again on the inhibitor.
If you start to
vary the thickness
within a print a
whole lot, it becomes
difficult to balance
the inhibitor.
Because as light is going
through this material,
as a reaction is
propagating, you
don't want that reaction
to propagate and turn
your whole resin into
a big ball of goo.
So we need ways to
start that reaction
and stop that reaction.
And Carbon 3D has their
own way to do that.
We have a very
different way to do
that, which gives us a lot
more control over how to start
and stop these reaction.
AUDIENCE: So what you do with
the leftover resin in the K-cup
model?
Because it seems that you
have a fixed amount of resin
for any K-cup and so is it
just because every single one
is going to be custom designed
for the part that's being made?
WALTER VOIT: Yes.
So for high-volume
manufacturing,
companies would be able to
specify exactly how much resin
they would need.
And we would have very little
waste at the end of the day.
In these cases, we pushed
the Z fluid up higher,
and then we polymerize
a little A3DT disk
at the top that's a
little knickknack that we
can play around with
and hand out as swag.
In the future for
highly customized parts,
that would be nearly
eliminated for more
of the maker community.
There would be
different SKUs you
could buy for
different size resins,
and then it would
be up to individuals
to determine what to
do with the extra.
But in most cases, you
would push it to the top
and then just finish
polymerizing it.
SRISHTI GOEL: So
the other thing is
we're actually, because of this
problem of having waste resin,
we're doing a lot of studies
now that are internally focused
on what kind of--
what quality of print
do we get if we
reuse our old resin.
And so we're seeing
that actually
if you use-- if you need
something that's low quality,
if you're not super concerned
about what kind of properties
you're going to get
on the end user,
then you can actually reuse the
resin and it works pretty well.
So we're actually working on
making that less of a waste
situation, more of a recyclable,
more sustainable solution
for having to deal with
that kind of thing.
WALTER VOIT: So the
question was whether we
were focused in medical
markets, because it seems
like this control of stiffness
and internal geometry
and materials properties would
lend themselves well to that.
That's something that, with
my other hat on for a moment,
back at the University
that we're spending
a good deal of time on.
We have a DARPA grant that
is focused on 3D printing
some artificial tracheas with
colleagues at UT Southwestern.
My wife is actually here
sitting in the back.
She's an ear, nose, and
throat, head and neck surgeon
at UT Southwestern.
And so we're working with her
and with some of her bosses
to do that.
But in terms of market
adoption for a small company,
you can live off of
grant funding and things
for a long time.
But in terms of
readiness to market,
there are quite a few
barriers to entry,
and we've focused a lot of
our immediate concentration
on these near-term,
high-value industrial markets.
And I think there's a huge
segment for medical research.
But that will come.
As a company is adaptive,
we've focused squarely
on the non-medical space so far.
But I think we'll
continue to build
an IP portfolio
that may lend itself
to that in the near future.
Thanks a lot for your time.